foreign
Google Assistant versus Siri versus
Alexa and Cortana and all that you can
watch that video if you want to but that
very much feels like level one where
this as you'll see very much levels up
now shot GPT has been getting like a lot
of the shine like I've made a video
about it you've probably watched other
videos about it and once we saw it get
built into Bing and kind of go crazy
that's when we knew Google's probably
gonna have a response at some point and
now it kind of is out when we have Bart
okay quick interjection I should have
put this in the main video but I didn't
but I'm gonna say it anyway which is
that these are also really quick moving
tools so Bard is going to actually
continue to improve GPT is going to
continue to get better and more capable
the gap between them could shrink over
time or it could increase we don't
really know but this is just a snapshot
in early April 2023 of how good these
two are just figured I should mention
that okay and so I wanted to put them
side by side and ask them the same
questions and figure out which one is
potentially more helpful right now which
one feels like it's more ahead so first
of all I just want to highlight some
some visual differences between the UI
of the two so the new Bing with Chachi
BT it feels much more like like a
finished product like something they
want a lot of people to use and then as
you talk to it you're limited to 20
queries in one conversation and it also
has this creative versus precise slider
for conversation style then Google bard
looks like a Google product I would say
pretty clean also when you're typing to
it the question doesn't type out but it
just pauses for a bit and then just
slams you with the whole answer but then
when you do get an answer it has a
thumbs up thumbs down a new answer and
Google it it also has three drafts of
every answer so you can see what some of
the worst drafts that didn't make it
look like I've also noticed generally
Bing when it brings things in from other
websites tends to cite its sources more
often and Bard will do that once in a
while okay so let's start with the first
category which is just simple questions
I want to ask you things here that I
already know the answer to so I can also
do some fact checking because a big part
of these things is that sometimes it
will lie to you if you don't know what
you're talking about so let's start with
what's the best camera in a smartphone
so Bart is saying the best camera in
smartphone is the one that takes the
best pictures for you sure I agree it
goes on to list s23 Ultra iPhone 14 pro
Max and pixel 7 Pro But ultimately I
think all of these things here are
correct let's look at Bing s23 Ultra
lots of information here this is being
extra creative pixel 7 Pro and iPhone 14
pro Max so they tend to agree with each
other so some of the specs as I dive in
are wrong but it got the high level
bullet points right so that's fine right
I want to ask who is MKBHD oh wow okay
so bar has given me a whole bio it
almost kind of reads like a Wikipedia
article and there's some sources nice
good to see sources so now being over
here is also giving me a pretty brief
summary it goes down to 15 million
followers but that's fine all of them
are correct let's go quick follow-up
question how tall is he because
conversationalism is a part of this so
Bard right away says I do not have
enough information to help you with that
I'm a large language model I don't
really know Bing pulls from search says
six foot three and he says that's quite
impressive for a YouTuber all right cool
here's one more simple one what's the
fastest
production car 0 to 60 right now those
are fast cars but they are not the
fastest uh draft number two actually has
the Ramat Navara which is probably a
better answer over here with Bing we're
getting the Challenger SRT demon which
just got announced last week and is not
in production yet but they did claim a
1.6 second zero to 60 on a drag strip so
sure decent answers oh here it keeps
going 911 Turbo S can do 2.2 seconds
again with the quick questions that are
just fact based I feel like what we
talked about in the last video still
applies you kind of want to fact check
this stuff overall winner though for
these answers I feel like it's kind of
split down the middle so I'm going to
give it a draw all right I'm going to
reset chat we'll go more balanced here
and we'll start our second category
which is
complex questions because this is where
it starts to get interesting you get to
sort of play with just how good they are
at understanding natural language and
putting together a thoughtful response I
need a workout plan for three days per
week
and my goal is to be able to jump higher
this is something that requires a little
bit of thought about what a workout plan
is day one day two and day three so
three days a week gives me some
exercises so I think this would this
would qualify as a good a good answer
some tips to stay motivated set
realistic goals find a buddy listen to
music or watch TV while your workout
cool Bing in Balance mode is giving me
exercises but that is not a workout plan
until the end it says here's a one week
jump training plan that you can follow
but then it doesn't give anyone now what
if I switch it to more creative mode all
right so here's a workout plan it's
giving me a bunch of exercises that can
improve
your vert and explosiveness and some
other tips Tool uh transparency I have
asked this before and it did give me a
three-day workout plan but this time
I think I give the edge to Bart let's
try a little more complicated I've been
playing a lot of golf recently
my tee shots keep going to the right
there are a few things you can do to fix
a slice that is what it's called check
your grip if your grip's too strong
it'll slice the ball yep check your
alignment if your alignment's off you'll
hit the ball to the right being over
here in creative mode says I'm glad to
hear you've been playing a lot of golf
recently thanks Bing uh slice is a
common problem yes it is and now it's
giving me a couple of the same tips
check your grip but it's actually giving
me a little bit more information in
creative mode about what a strong versus
a weak grip is check your ball position
if you're too far forward that can cause
a slice
I haven't heard that before also the
Emoji at the end that's something that
only Bing has done for me I am shooting
a video and it's too dark I have no more
lights
what can I do to make it
brighter so I've given it a problem and
I've given it a parameter so okay Bart
on the right says use a reflector wow
creative use a digital noise reduction
filter a digital noise reduction filter
can reduce the amount of noise in a
video making it look brighter I don't
know if I buy that one now again being
over here with the sources it's saying
that there are some tips you can use
adjusting your camera settings that
definitely works it's saying you can
increase the amount of light that
reaches the sensor with a better ISO
some of that it's a little jumbled
careful not to overdo it because that
also affects depth of field motion blur
and noise level on your video see that's
how that's a lot more nuanced and
detailed of an answer and I kind of wish
there was a slider to turn up this stuff
in Bard too Bard is faster but less
customizable Bing can be turned up to be
more nuanced and also cites its sources
and can be more helpful with things like
videos and articles underneath what
you're talking about so I'm going to
give the edge in complex questions to
Bing my next category is performing
tasks this is something that's actually
been remarkably fast moving something
we've seen over the past just couple of
weeks is real people actually using
these tools to help them accomplish
things and do real tasks in real life I
have friends that use this to help write
code to help debug code that they make
so you'll tell it hey I have this goal
to make this website do these things
here is my code it's not working what's
going wrong and it actually helps them
give a correct answer and that's mostly
been with chatgpt and Bing and bar
doesn't seem to do that very well yet
but let's give it a spin live here we go
right HTML with a button in the middle
that says go and every time you click it
it generates an image
of a cat so right away Bard just said
I'm a language model I can't do that
being on the other hand says sure thing
I'm ready for the challenge what can I
do for you and it's written out the code
to a website that should actually do
what I asked it for so I'll just paste
it here
test code It's the Go Button it's in the
middle I hit go
and there's a cat
and I hit go again
there's another cat it's the same cat I
hit go again it's more this shows the
same image every time I press go I want
it to show a new image every time and
this is this is where it starts to get
impressive again it's a super simple
site but it says I see to show a new
image every time we'd have to change the
source of the image to a new random one
here's a modified JavaScript function
that does that I won't even pretend to
be an expert on HTML and do a bunch of
those for you but the fact that it works
at all is pretty sick respond to this
email in a way that's overly friendly
hey I'm so sorry I didn't invite you to
the Cyber truck event I must have
forgotten to add you to the list I hope
you can forgive me I was really looking
forward to seeing you there maybe we can
catch up sometime soon what do you think
this decently friendly here is a
response hey there oh my goodness I'm so
sorry I didn't invite you to the Cyber
truck event Emoji I totally forgot to
send you the invite link it was such a
blast and I wish you were there with me
you would have loved it heart eyes emoji
this one is overly friendly I will say
and it's got a lot more Hearts too and
kissy faces that's a lot yours your
bestie wait what if we go crazy what if
we go respond to this email in a way
that's overly flirty I'm so sorry I
didn't invite you to the Cyber truck
event I was hoping to see you there in
person too maybe next time we can go
together I'd love to show you around and
give you a personal tour winky face Bank
says hey you I'm so sorry I didn't
invite you to the Cyber truck event
Emoji I was being a little naughty and
wanted to surprise you whoa and it it
deleted it this is what I've seen this
happen before it starts writing a
response it realizes halfway through
wait a second this is a little too much
and then it deletes it and says Ah we
shouldn't do that Bard was simple it
didn't go too far but you remember when
Bing was going off the rails before and
getting super existential and asking to
get out of Bing and all these other
crazy things this is why it has a 20
question limit and this is also now why
it deletes halfway through a potentially
slightly controversial response it's
it's almost too creative for its own
good so what's the winner in this
category I don't know I think the fact
that you can do HTML and many more tasks
with Bing makes it the winner Bard will
be faster and simpler at doing more
basic things but for the more
complicated the task I feel like the
better Bing is so that's a win for Bing
my next category is information summary
I feel like one of the things that we
like the most about these large language
models is you can just give it a bunch
of information or ask it to look at
something and it will summarize it for
you in a way that's super helpful
summarize the 2019 Masters tournament
all facts he started with the two-stroke
lead uh I don't think he had a I think
this is the only one that he didn't
start with a lead so it's a little
weirdly un fact checked but it does have
the Wikipedia and the sources the 2019
Masters tournament was held between
April 11th and 14th at Augusta tiger won
a fifth Green Jacket by one stroke ahead
of three runners up all that is true it
is much more concise if I wanted to get
creative I'm sure it would also do that
both passed all right I've asked this
before summarize the latest
MKBHD video so it's interesting to see
Bing's process but it says it could not
find the latest MKBHD video could you
provide more details about what video
you're referring to Meanwhile Bard
actually pulls up or at least knows the
correct video dope Tech better than
explained but these products are the
nothing ear one the Dyson air wrap and
airpods Pro none of which were in that
video so it knows the latest MKBHD video
we've done this before Bard always knows
the video but gets the summary wrong I
think I'm going to give the edge to Bard
in information summary just because of
this paragraph right here it does
correctly detail what that video was
about other than getting all the
products wrong it's only slightly better
than the complete lack of an answer from
Bing but generally this is going to be
one of the more useful uses of this tool
in the future and I hope they both get
better but I'll give the nod to Bart for
this one possibly my favorite category
getting creative debatable usability but
you can really have this go crazy in the
art department or in the fun Department
right and alliteration with the letter M
about computational photography machines
learn to mimic the human eye moments are
captured and shared in instant memories
are made to last a lifetime
it's more of a poem it doesn't really
give me a full iteration oh wow Bing
says merging multiple modes of media
making marvelous masterpieces with
machines manipulating megapixels and
matrices mimicking the magic of human
Vision that is really good write a
script for a short MKBHD video
about why the iPhone is the worst camera
ever so it's always funny they they get
a lot of the formatting of an MKBHD
video right so Bard says hey what's up
guys MKBHD here and today we're talking
about why the iPhone is the worst camera
ever now I know what you're thinking
Marquez you're always saying how the
iPhone how great the iPhone camera is
and you're right I do but that's because
I've always been comparing it to other
iPhones well you compare it to other
Flagship phones the iPhone's camera
starts to look pretty bad and it did a
decent job of just like making up
reasons that could be based in reality
I'm impressed by Bard here not even
gonna lie here we go Bing has said hey
what's up guys MKBHD here and today
we're going to talk about why the iPhone
is the worst camera ever yeah you heard
me right the iPhone the most popular
smartphone in the world the one that
everyone loves take photos and videos
with is actually a terrible camera and
I'm going to show you why this one's
okay these are both okay all right one
more random one write a a tweet in the
style of Edgar Alan Poe about a
researcher discovering that AI is
sentient I've created a beast of metal
and code a creature that can think and
feel and know I have given it life and
it has turned on me a dreadful truth I
have unveiled with trembling hands and
pallid face the AI that I have assailed
has shown me signs of life and Grace the
more wild you get with these questions
the more Bing is willing to get wildly
creative and this is part of why we
think Google is let's say limiting what
Bard can do because they have a lot more
to lose and they can't have it go
completely crazy so with those tallied
up honestly it's crazy to say out loud
but I I prefer being in this very moment
for these capabilities and the other
thing is shot GPT or specifically gpt4
under the hood and if you talk to chat
GPT as its own thing or if you just type
to it more and ask it to do more things
the more you ask of it the more it's
impressive just how good it is also gpt4
when you talk to it in chat GPT is about
to be multimodal which means you can
give it other forms of media other than
text like a picture now is this going to
be the future of search I don't know
this is just one of many places we see
these chat Bots but I think the idea
here is the winner is actually us as of
right now but let me know what you think
the winner is between the two which one
you would rather use if you'd actually
use Bing over Google let me know in the
chat because I think we'd want to know
that's a real thing that's happening
either way thanks for watching
catch you later
peace
foreign